so there's a lot of misinformation about
what's working on YouTube right now so
in this video I'm going to be breaking
down a secret that I found on YouTube
that ultimately helped me get not just
only a gold play button uh but three
silver play buttons and you can apply
this and what's cool about this strategy
is that you don't need a better camera
you don't need any significant levels of
talent you don't really need to improve
your video skills and you actually don't
even need to be very consistent with
this strategy I actually found a cool
way to ethically hack into people's
brains and I took a screenshot of my
December recap on my think media channel
and it revealed some information that I
think is super powerful so if you
download the YouTube studio app it'll
give you a recap some months and so in
the month of December
2023 you'll notice that
75% of the views gotten on my think
media channel were from video that were
published over six months ago now
depending on how you're measuring
success that might actually be like well
why aren't your new videos doing very
well but I would flip it on that
observation and it would say actually
why aren't your old videos doing better
than your new videos why would you want
to make new videos that get views and
then crash as opposed to create videos
that continue to get views for weeks
months and years to come so 7
5% were watching older of of my content
being watched was from six months or uh
or older now consider this I'm in
lenworth Washington here's a few photos
of my wife Sonia and I and this is a
brarian Christmas Town uh over the
mountains in the Pacific Northwest and
so while I'm on vacation at this place
called The Post Hotel that's like got a
it's got like ice baths steam baths dry
saunas pressure points on your foot the
whole kind of thing ultimately I'm
getting views on my library of content
that's over six months old and so how do
you tap into that and how can you apply
that well in this video I want to share
with you three formulas that we're going
to apply to three different free tools
so definitely stick around until the end
and because this is the coffee with Kel
Show if you have a question just put
four question marks before and after and
I'll get to those and then check out
time codes and chapters so you can watch
the beginning training as well as
ultimately uh tap into any of the Q&A
that you want to if you happen to be
watching this on the replay and if
you're pumped for 2024 smash the like
button so ultimately what we're talking
about as far as the secret that I found
was the power of using the YouTube
search bar which is free to come up with
video ideas that people uh ultimately
want to watch and to come up with
Evergreen video ideas you know I just
was looking the YouTube studio and
YouTube was emphasizing themselves like
advice from YouTube that they said
create more Evergreen content so that
ultimately your library gets more views
over time don't just Chase Trends not
saying that's bad don't just Chase
Trends but also create Evergreen content
but how can we do it well let's look at
some of these tools in the YouTube
search bar and uh the first one we have
three YouTube top IC formulas and I'm
going to be breaking all three of these
down and I would love for you to let me
know what is your Niche uh is there a
giveaway yes at the end of the video
Michael I'm going to be dropping the
secret word so let me know what is your
Niche and I'm actually going to be doing
this live with our community here as far
as coming up with different topics now
why is this such a secret well the
problem that 99% of creators struggle
with is they're making videos that
nobody wants to watch or they're looking
for video ideas and they're looking in
all the wrong places like some people
are also looking for love in all the
wrong places um but ultimately we're
going to use these three title uh um
formulas and the first one number one is
how to number one is how to so for DIY
and woodworking is our first Niche from
the dad cave and I'll switch up the
niche on each formula um we're going to
go to the YouTube search bar and we're
going to type in how
to build
a table okay so ultimately what we're
tapping into in this this powerful
secret maybe you've heard of this before
but most people don't understand even
how to use this tool or or ways to use
it so I promise you you're going to get
a couple insights that are going to help
you get more views in 2024 so what we're
using is when we tap into the YouTube
search bar it's doing a couple things
for us number one it's revealing what
people are actually searching so if you
type in howto it's the predictions this
Auto complete is letting us know what
people are actually searching so if you
have a
woodworking channel so you could type in
Woodworking and immediately you start
getting all kinds of vide topic ideas
woodworking projects that sell
woodworking project ideas woodworking
tools great so you can take your topic
your Niche and you can start
brainstorming different video ideas now
this is better than AI this is better
than other tools those tools are fine
too but the reason this is powerful is
because it's actually Based on data of
what people are actually searching on
YouTube so it's verified that people are
interested in these topics it's not just
like hey chat GPT like what are 30 video
ideas like okay great but those are this
video ideas what if we could actually
verify what people are interested in and
so if we take in something like
woodworking uh you can take your topic
and you could say how
to and even though how to woodworking is
kind of a bad sentence immediately I
start getting this
rich list ordered by most search to Lee
searched so how to do woodworking
projects how to woodworking video how to
start woodworking as a hobby how to
start a woodworking business and then
this is where things like human
psychology come in in such an important
way for example human psychology
understanding of who are you trying to
reach on YouTube understanding of what's
the type of person talking to and what I
mean by that is you know if if you're
trying to do YouTube work uh woodworking
as a hobby versus as a business that's
like two entirely different mindsets so
it'll help us kind of drill down and
what we can do is you don't just like
take it at face value if it's how to
start woodworking is a a hobby or how to
set up a woodworking shop this is why
the first Formula of how to is is what
you want to start playing with like how
to build a
DIY could be the next thing you think
about because uh the co the uh Community
member that shared this Niche shared DIY
in woodworking so how to build a DIY
chair and then DIY how to build a
folding campfire chair maybe irrelevant
because you're not going to do folding
stuff but maybe you are so you start you
start going down this robbit hole how to
build a do-it-yourself
table would and and then a couple things
that we begin to learn one if if you hit
a dead end and nothing is predicted it
should cause you to pause two if you hit
a dead end it's okay to go back and then
start reworking it because if you go
well Sean it doesn't work for me nothing
is predicted that should cause you pause
because that would indicate that no one
is looking for those videos now you
doesn't mean you can't make that video
there's a whole other approach to
YouTube by having a lot of curiosity
even the title of this video is I found
a YouTube secret that's not actually a
search it's not a how to term it's even
a different approach in the way I
packaged this but don't get it twisted
one of the best ways to start is to
start with the search based revealed by
YouTube insights that YouTube gives you
in fact I'll give you three reasons why
this is so powerful and we'll go into
these other formulas as well but the
reason this is so powerful is because
again hereo thic media our commitment to
you this year is to help you win on
YouTube help you get into the top 2% of
YouTube creators which means get over
10,000
subscribers help you do this
full-time and also we've we deeply study
not just sort of like the what to do
because everybody knows what to do like
everybody knows that it's New Year's and
like you should eat better and like work
out and like cut out toxic friends but
the what to do actually isn't the hard
part it's more like the psychology the
momentum how do I get myself motivated
how do I get out of a rut so the three
reasons why this is powerful is because
you start with easy videos like when you
reveal when we some of the formulas that
we're going to use and what it's going
to reveal for us are going to give us
what we're looking for is like oh
that'll be an easy video some people
over complicate YouTube there are videos
you could make in 2024 sh shot just on
your smartphone you don't need a fancy
camera with very basic beginner
information but the reason why you'll
succeed is because you identified a
particular topic it wasn't because of a
fancy title or thumbnail let's improve
those as well because you did better
research using the tools that YouTube
gives you and in doing so when you
identify a particular video it doesn't
mean that it has to be hard to be
successful so you start with easy videos
number two you start with videos people
want to watch we know that for sure
because if you follow the process I'm
going to be breaking down here we have
verified that people want to watch them
and number three check this
out you you'll get guaranteed views I
can't guarantee you'll go viral you
probably won't but I can guarantee
you'll get views because if you do this
right it will lead to views because
instead of just making random videos
that no one's actually looking for
you're creating strategic videos that
people want to see so title formula
number one is how to and we've been
using woodworking it could be how to
build and it could be like how to again
we learned this one set up a woodworking
shop or how to set up a woodworking
I just saw it how to set up a
woodworking how to set up your
woodworking shop now for example if we
if we found this one and for the person
that submitted this Niche think about
this you might be able to literally
Vlog around your shop that's already set
up and this is why this could be so
powerful is because for most of
us we are probably sitting on some video
ideas that are within Arms Reach we just
don't see them
so I don't know if you've made the how
to set up your woodworking shop but if
it's somewhat cool and you just think
about like how do I set this up I put
this here this here maybe you outline
the video really quick so you make like
a quick you get like a t you know your
Journal your tablet you're like this was
the thought was like kind of like one
two three four five oh there's the five
things there's your YouTube chapters and
then you're like hey are you curious
about how to set up your Woodworking
Shop wow the hook was just identified
because we were just using this how to
set up your woodworking shop
and then you know you look at we'll get
to this later but if you look at the
other videos that are
successful um the evening woodworker
here said workshop design five keys to
small shop layout by the way your
research here does not mean this should
be your final title what we're
identifying is topics so work workshop
design five keys to a small shop layout
okay cool uh and you you look at a video
like this and you go oh okay I can make
that and add that to my library and
here's one of the things that's so
fascinating is I really believe this in
2024 you should make more basic videos
and more videos that maybe seem obvious
but just are like hidden in plain sight
because maybe this one you know again
seems dumb but it's actually really
smart so anyways howto would be the
first one so how could you apply how
to in front of your Niche your topic and
then of course there's a zillion
opportunities like how to use a
particular woodworking tool how to so
how to is the first one let's talk about
the second one the second one is versus
and give me some more uh topics what are
your channel topics I'm going to do a
different one so if you're just joining
we're going through a YouTube secret
which is using the YouTube search bar to
identify topics that have verified
entrance that people actually want to
watch and if possible that are actually
pretty quick and easy to make because
it's not about the production value it's
about the content value
so our first channel topic was
Woodworking and if we found this topic
how to set up a woodworking shop and if
you're living this lifestyle meaning
whatever your channel is you live the
lifestyle of your channel topic like I
live the lifestyle of a content creator
so I could easily make a how how I
organized or how I set up my workstation
how I set up my battle station with
these different cameras I have made that
video but you know I could I could talk
about or I could talk about how I what
do I travel with on the road it's just
you're living the life lifestyle so
you're making a video that isn't
necessarily hard to make why because
you're living it you've already set up
the woodworking shop so you shoot it on
your phone shoots a b-roll organize it
quickly and might I make a point
whenever you see and because I have vid
IQ installed a channel that has more
views on a video than their subscribers
you've identified a powerful topic that
has so much interest in it the interest
is bigger than the influence Ence of the
channel that's worth taking a sip of
coffee on the coffee with cand show to
think about what that mean when the
interest is bigger in the topic than the
channel itself because too many people
make the mistake they want to be an
influencer and they have no influence so
some people get views because they have
millions of subscribers they could be
really entertaining very charismatic
that's why I said this doesn't take a
fancy camera or Talent it does take
though some experience something
valuable that you can convey on camera
and the topic
itself 500,000 people over the last
three years so this person experienced
the evening woodworker experienced what
I just experienced when I was at a a
resort with my wife over the holidays
still getting views this video gets more
views than the person's influence and
it's still getting views three years
later because we're reverse engineering
this method again number one using
YouTube title formulas from the YouTube
search bar with how to let's go to
number two two which is versus one of my
favorite kind of videos versus all right
so the next topic I'm just clicking
these randomly in streamyard mra's got a
channel on passive income and Financial
Freedom okay so I'm going to assume it's
maybe personal finance of some kind or
uh passive income okay so let's talk
versus so let's go back to how to so how
to make passive
income great uh this was number one
formulas how to and then fill in the
blank how to make passive
income um with chat GPT All I'm gonna
what I'm looking for now because you
know your Niche better than me okay so
how to make passive income with chat GPT
and medium these are interesting and
we'll get to this a little bit later but
actually typing in the search like using
the search bar discovering the topic and
then seeing what's on the other side can
give you a lot of insights as you're
brainstorming but here's all I was
looking for I was looking for two two
things to compare and I found them
so let's use chat
GPT versus some other stuff in fact one
of the things that's most powerful about
this is I don't even know what the other
stuff is we're about to find out
together live chat GPT
versus
now my heart has been tickled uh my
heart goes beep beep what are we okay
relax so chat GPT versus stockfish I
don't even know what stockfish is now
you might and I know you were saying
passive income but what we want to do is
follow this Rabbit Trail of
curiosity
and if we can make money with chat gbt
could we make money with
stockfish so you're saying your Niche is
passive income Financial Freedom great
but what we want to actually do is then
within your Niche focus in on okay what
are some ways of creating passive income
there's literally thousand okay great
are you doing some stuff with AI now I'm
making a lot of assumptions if you're
like I know nothing about Ai and chat
gbt well you have two options you could
go research for 10 20 30 40 hours and
then turn that into a video could be
very effective you'll get smarter in the
process this is literally why the
YouTube the content creator career is
the greatest career if you love the
topic that you're into because for some
it might sound awful to go research for
20 hours but if you're researching and
reading about and studying what you love
then it's kind of fun to do it sure it's
work still you know but it's kind of fun
to do it and then it's a benefit to the
viewer because I would love to watch a
video about um stockfish and some other
things understand what the different
opportunities are so let's say like chat
versus stockfish we're going to do the
search um it's a meme maybe I don't know
what it is okay broke chess just solved
chess okay so chat GPT so that so by the
way this is why you also got to go
deeper because apparently what that was
was maybe chat gbt beat a chess bot or a
chess AI perhaps so let's actually go
chat GPT versus Bard I do know what BART
is The Showdown great now where we could
go as deeper on this and give me a
couple more niches because let me try
another one here but chat GPT versus
Bard like make money or let's go money
I'm just going to press enter here
because I'm wondering about people are
obviously making money which is right
for you okay okay great so and I might
abandon this this path because I'm still
trying to get into the head of what your
Niche is but let's say um let's go
passive income passive
income uh real
estate versus stock market investing
that would be a direct passive
income
comparison which one will make you more
money which one is more
passive which one is more and and in
Verses Of course this is Dave and Dave's
influence but that's a lot of views 1.4
million views uh it's not even close
Bigger Pockets 23,000 views so that
would be another way to think about
versus but let's let's do one more on
this title
formula um
uh or one more Niche tell me your
niches tell me I'll go back up to to
find one off the grid cooking Katie's
Camp
kitchen so we're talking about
three topic YouTube topic formulas that
if you use these
wisely will lead to guaranteed views in
2024 and our first one was how to our
second one is versus and our next Niche
here on versus is camp offgrid cooking
so I need information you already
probably have this let's go tents for
camp
camping number one a good video top five
tents for camping what's interesting is
on the other side is kind of a side
quest here is how many of these are
faceless videos see people are out here
trying to buy now and you probably
should because if you're building a
personal brand maybe like this person
you've actually been there and it's your
own footage and you've tested it but
these top two videos just again as a
side quest are like like scripts written
from chat GPT random b-roll of stuff and
then like probably affiliate links oh
they didn't even link it up somebody
didn't do their job us and worldwide
links no links so anyways you can see
that this is a uh a faceless Channel
what that [__] Inspire is just the fact
that there's more videos you can create
without having to go buy every tent in
the world it is in my opinion or you
might say hey I'm I'm I'm doing a
rundown I haven't necessarily tried all
these but I just I've researched this
magazine and outdoor magazine and I did
this and I called two friends and here's
now the final list this is the one I've
tried I've tried this one as well here's
the other three that are popular those
were out of my price range like you
could get into more affiliate marketing
stuff again without having to like buy a
lot of products but that was some a
niche side quest for those that are fans
of the channel um and know some of these
topics that we talk about a lot so
here's what I'm after
I am after uh okay North Face white duck
Coleman Eureka so I'm going to say white
duck
tent
versus so right there here it is here's
the secret idea the only thing that came
up at least in in terms of these two
Browns the only thing that came up was
white
duck and Kodiak tent so what that tells
me though is again you can't get
romantic if you're like well and I bet
Coleman's on there too but if like
Coleman doesn't come up you can make the
video but don't be surprised when it
doesn't get the views using this process
is key because we're verifying
interest like imagine if you were going
to go to a friend's house they're
throwing a party you're with your
girlfriend boyfriend
spouse and and you're like Hey we're
going to a party tonight and your wife
goes are you sure the party is happening
do you know it's happening for sure and
you're like yeah I mean I think it
is uh and she said it's two hours away
like I don't want to drive two hours if
I if you haven't even got a text back
and you're not sure the party is
happening and you're like well I don't
know I think it will and so then you get
in your car you drive two hours you get
there the house is locked the lights are
off and the part is not happening what's
my point of sharing that my point is if
you haven't
verified that the party was happening
before you went on the two-hour Journey
then you're going to be really
frustrated when you get there and
there's no party
too many people make YouTube videos
where they haven't verified the topic
they're about to make they spend hours
of work creating the video they spend
all this thought creating the video and
then they're disappointed when the part
is not happening and there's no views
this is why we're verifying interest so
if if I'm GNA make not only a versus
video which by the way could lead to a
lot of monetization opportunities um I'm
G to go Kodiak tent versus white duck
because that was what was recommended to
me on the other side of that I'm going
to see okay Kodiak versus spring Bart
tense interestingly enough now and we're
not spending I'm going to keep moving
through these formulas but I don't even
know if anyone's made this video because
Spring Bar unless Spring Bar is white
duck and again forgive me for tent
ignorance I don't really go outside just
that's not true but kind of uh the last
tent you ever buy so the white duck but
this white duck is not even being
compared and this is what I mean when I
say every day we discover video ideas
that think media that have not been made
for people who say YouTube is crowded
for people who say YouTube is
oversaturated I'm like well then why has
nobody made the codiac tent versus the
white duck tent video yet people really
want to see it and you compare those two
tents with affiliate links now you got
passive income 50 to 100 bucks a month
coming in passively and that video will
be watched for the next three
years time to get the tents maybe borrow
one do you have one of those now let's
try one other one let's go like uh what
was it co Kodak C gate Cole Coleman
Coleman Coleman 10 more popular this
also why can be powerful to cover more
popular products because people are
actually searching for them so the
Coleman tent versus the Ozark Trail tent
great okay here you go this and this's a
that's a good thumbnail Coleman versus
Ozark Trail nice versus nice thumbnail
10,000 views very
Niche uh top topic but really great for
your library arguably not super
difficult to make these
are link affiliate links to a $300 $200
tent here's a $35 attent and and I would
argue this video is ranked and gonna be
ranked for a long time if not you know
ever you got another one here also for a
new channel outdoor FAQs remember what
we talked about earlier only 7
subscribers but 409 views the views are
out influencing the Channel's influence
why because of following the research
following this process following this
YouTube secret of using YouTube topic
formulas
to ultimately um come up with great
video ideas that again no fancy camera
needed not even a ton of talent needed
just some experience and let hit number
three is best now I'll tell you about a
resource we have in just a second
that'll just give you even more of this
but these three are really good place to
start so howto versus invest and we're
using the YouTube search bar let me get
one more niche in the comments smash
like if you're getting value and and let
me know if you like trainings like this
where we're getting really tactical and
really
granular um but let's dive into this
third one and then I have three tools
that are going to take this research
deeper um and so number three is best
and we need another topic so let's go
gaming news nerdcore nerd cave so gaming
news this will be
fun to what what stands out to me is
it's going to be naturally
best
PS5 games
2023 now okay that's that's some big
competition but appr proven formula
right so and that was predict that was
handed to us that one might have been a
little bit more obvious top 10 best PS5
games now watch Mojo it's going to be
hard to beat them push Square never
heard of them but maybe they're on the
rise
push Square makes sense okay the square
button on a PS5 smart trademark even
what is this new channel okay but what
would be the opportunity here would be
to be go deeper so let's actually go
best uh
PS5
and what we want to do and here's now
some tactics around the search bar best
PS5
space um
I because I was I was leaning Indie but
indie games but then also notice that I
know you said gaming news but notice
just all the different insights we're
getting here that could lead us
different directions the best internal
SSD now again another big opportunity
you're a gaming channel but what's the
best internal SSD best paying for your
buck size can works with the machine the
best that's another money-making
opportunity for affiliate marketing
because you could link to the SSD drive
on Amazon or new egg or whever internet
settings now again if you're gaming news
you might not be as practical as this
but notice this is very interesting but
I was leaning more indie games so we go
indie games and I put another space keep
going deeper is one of the tips on the
search bar best PS5 space Indie Space
games so then you get best indie horror
games PS5 and then it does stop like I
think it it pretty much stops here
but you now could take it further
meaning you could say
2023 you could
say other nuances like that you might
end up saying top five top three a lot
of people doing top 10 lists there's
there's some fascinating reasons to do
top
50 Ultra long form videos quote unquote
are underestimate you know time codes
chapters top 50 best indie horror games
I don't know like is there even that
many but like then people going through
they skip through through maybe the
video doesn't get massive watch time but
people are like 50 like there's probably
a game on that list I don't know about
so this all happened and a niche that I
really am not that educated on from
using this search bar with these
formulas right and so let's do one other
niche in regards to this um let's go
okay let's go evangelism we are all over
the board here Benjamin thanks so much
for being here so evangelism so like
best
evangelism
uh couple things that we see here now I
didn't know what would be predicted but
I think the mistake a lot of people make
is they get romantic about the video
ideas that they want to they want to
make what do I mean romantic the you're
making videos for yourself you're making
videos based on your emotions which you
feel you haven't actually researched and
verified interest and then you're also
complaining to me and you're frustrated
with the review with the views you're
getting what would happen if you
researched before you pressed record and
got clear on what people were actually
asking for so interestingly enough is
you go best evangelism Now TV shows on
HBO Max that's not relevant best
evangelism sermon is interesting you
could get into a fair use in like aspect
of that maybe making a compilation of
some of the best evangelism sermons
maybe even tiing the video best
evangelism sermon maybe you don't want
to go that direction that's a thought by
the way that's what the audience is
saying they desire but the one that
stood out to me best read evangelism you
could do highlights of that and people
could learn from you're still
accomplishing the same thing but right
there that Nuance Street just changed
everything because now people are
probably wanting to watch that because
they're probably wanting to learn
some methods
some like Frameworks some uh apologetics
some ways of communicating the gospel
some ways of communicating their faith
or they're entertained by like there
could be a lot of reasons but that's
interesting but the one that stood out
to me is best books on
evangelism okay cool let's go ahead and
search it you will want this book for
evangelism here is one video that is
only one minute long that is an ad from
an actual book publisher that is the top
rank video five years ago someone did 10
books every Christian should read 13
books that change my life but here's
what's interesting the top five books in
60 seconds on evangelism okay so there's
there's one did pretty good too by the
way I mean oh 3,000 views but seven
years here's what I would say the
mistake is here is all these videos are
too
short so I think not that they're too
short but one 2024 make sure you
subscribed to this channel think media
podcast or if you like listening on
audio I've got some Banger videos coming
with top seven biggest TR trends for
2024 let me leak to you Trend number one
on my
list and in
2024 I'm going into my Google Docs
here uh
Trend I've got seven big trends did did
about 20 hours of research
probably not even sure where my notes
are my Google Docs you don't want to see
in there it's pretty pretty disorganized
uh January
video shoot is how I titled this okay
here we go doesn't matter so here's
here's the the trends but here's the one
that I want to bring up here this will
rock your world I hope number one
actually on the list high quality High
effort long form YouTube videos will
continue to dominate videos will
continue to get longer with video
viewership increasing on connected
TVs longer YouTube content is seen
serious success podcasts are pushing one
to two hour range and we're seeing top
creators push into the 25 to 30 minute
range on videos with higher average
viations deeper audience connections uh
Colin and Samir predicted this as well I
saw this happening because I was
noticing so many channels like just go
look at the result like go look at
channels look at Mr Beast videos look at
um that guy that does these videos that
always get a million views uh they
always go viral about like why your
supplements they're kind of like video
essays supplements are bad uh by the way
ruined my world because I spend a
zillion dollars on supplements and
Johnny Harris so if you ever seen like
Johnny Harris so 29 minutes his videos
are 29 minutes and and they're all
getting now these are very difficult
videos and again this video ruin my life
but or just showed me I was probably
wasting a lot of money and probably
poisoning myself but that your
supplements are a lie thanks Johnny so
um so I mean 21 minutes 29 minutes and
by the way of course this one's just
came
out there's there's too many things to
compare on this channel but let me just
make a point that the video that's 11
minutes has a a lot less views than the
video that is
21 there's a lot of I I know somebody be
like oh that's you know kind of well but
and and it could be topic people maybe
watch the channel they don't care about
the recap I'm just saying though that
notice the views at you know I here's 13
1.8 38 though got 2.1 this one
subjective channel the bottom line is
high effort high quality long form
videos I would be focusing on that in
2024 and so if we full if we go full
circle back
to where what the research we're talking
about should lead you to notice a video
I just recently did said this book is a
cheat code for Content creation and my
video about one book was actually a 30
minute video I read the book which which
is a heavy lift that a lot of people
don't want to do I took copious notes I
then synthesized them into a video made
for you let me know if you watch that
video this this book is a cheat code
it's on the laws of communication from
Maxwell and the videoos outperforming
other videos on the channel it's rising
and notice too like even the way that
video was
positioned was different than what our
research is doing uh here but but
nevertheless we're verifying okay do
people want to read books on evangelism
what is what could we learn from the
videos that are already out and that was
a long side quest to just say I think
they're they're too short I think that
if you were
to if you also spot different formulas
like people saying I read 117 Finance
books here's the 17 things that really
matter what's fascinating about that
formula is nobody wants to read the7
books and it's this whole idea that when
you save people time when you get people
good information and you are a
synthesizer anyways so just a couple
thoughts on you maybe wouldn't have
thought we would have gone to Street
evangelism books on evangelism when you
mentioned your channel was about
evangelism you could have been thinking
about something else which reveals to me
that there is massive opportunities that
you can't see yet like if you ever see
somebody who's doing better on YouTube
than you
are it's probably because there's
something they're doing that you don't
know that's why getting information and
and and learning and being a part of
streams like this is huge because
there's whole series of videos or whole
clusters of video topics that would be
so relevant for your channel I would
even argue they're loow hanging fruit
but sometimes they're may be hard to see
or sometimes you dishonor it sometimes
we like have this martyr complex where
we're like I don't want the lwh hanging
fruit I want to climb to the top of the
tree get cut up by the branches just to
prove you know like it's not necessarily
the person who puts in the most time or
whatever you might be able to find a
quick video like we started this whole
stream on doing like how to set up your
woodworking shop where you're like I'm
going to shoot that right now like
thanks Sean I'm gonna go shoot it just
shot it on my phone like stitched it
together now it's the best performing
video on my channel not because of a
camera not because of talent because of
the right information because of the
right research tools and applying the
information we discover properly okay so
I got to share the three tool we talked
about the three formulas here they are
again we're using the YouTube search bar
I showed that on my thick media channel
the majority of my views in December
came from content that was six months
old and of course we should do new
Banger content but our approach I think
media is leverage I want to be hanging
with my wife chilling in a hot tub you
know while I'm still getting views and
making passive income the only way you
do that is Evergreen content the only
way you do that is content that has a
longer shelf life and if you use these
three formulas the three YouTube topic
formulas as how to versus invest those
will be really helpful and um there's a
lot more in fact if you haven't heard
about it uh today's coffee with can is
brought to you by think Medias sal.com
and um this is a really cool bundle of
downloadable PDFs um online courses uh
canva templates for thumbnails it
includes our YouTube Clarity blueprint
if you really want to get clear on um
your strategy for 2024 and I think it's
only
$57 for two more days the sale ends this
Saturday so think medas sale.com Link in
the description down below one of the
resources in there is our 15 best
YouTube title formulas guide and so the
howto the
verses um and the other one I just
shared with you the best uh I believe
those are a couple of them but if you
found that it valuable at all it's like
skip going to Olive gardom once and you
could pick pick up the think Medias
sale.com like it's a pretty no-brainer I
think you're going to love it so check
that out and if you like this kind of
stuff it'll only help you get better
results oh and this Saturday I'm doing a
threeh hour uh YouTube roadmap workshop
and it includes a ticket to that so
that's a live stream event I'm going to
be going through if if you want help
planning getting clear putting getting
your mindset right getting your strategy
right and learning more tips like I'm
sharing here it's kind of a a lots
packed in think me l.com Link in the
description to check it out okay let's
go deeper though on what we're learning
with these three YouTube tools and here
they are so the first one is YouTube
search the second one is Google Trends
and the third is Google search well Sean
what those aren't even tools well
actually they are and let's break down
how you could use them so give me some
more niches more of your topics here if
you're just joining this is an
interactive stream and what we're doing
now is as we've used YouTube search bar
and how it
has
autocomplete and it finishes our thought
how to set up a woodworking shop then we
kind of hone in on an idea like how to
set up a Woodworking Shop you know then
what we want to do is go deeper to make
the topic or our final video idea more
Rich more complete more unique because
we're not just looking for like basic
copy whatever other people are doing we
want to dig a little bit
deeper so Sylvia if you have more give
me a couple topics so I know what you
mean by lifestyle for women over
50 and then um let's go I'll go with
Olga graphic design tutorials here next
so let's talk about some graphic design
tutorials and what we're going to do is
we're going to use the YouTube search
bar first so let's say like okay how
to
crop photos in canva by the way
education software education education
channels like the one we're looking at
right here this topic are so powerful
because there's so many Ultra specific
questions like the one I'm coming up
with right now how to crop photos in
Photoshop oh no no no I don't want
Photoshop how to crop photos in canva I
don't know if you're using canva but
just follow me follow the the
breadcrumbs of and so okay first let's
get clear on the paino so people want to
know how to resize a photo in in uh
canva for free they want to crop an
image in canva circle how do you crop a
circle photo interesting okay cut and
and your opportunity here what what
would happen for a channel like yours is
you might have just got your five next
video ideas and back to the fact you
don't need a new camera if you have this
set up I'm using streamyard stream
withth think.com
like share screen hey welcome back I'm
in this video I'm going to show you how
to crop photos
in canva or I probably wouldn't even
open like that I would say all right so
here's how you crop a photo a circle
photo in canva step one and I would just
be sharing my screen as I'm doing here
and then I'd be brief be bright be fun
to be done and you just make a video in
fact and so this is then how we could
maybe see how much competition is on the
other side of one of these and that is
the
first tip of the first tool what I mean
by Tool is you're using YouTube search
as a
tool to look
up how to crop circle photos on Campbell
canva
mobile notice that some vertical only
screen share
video with a
voiceover now I don't want to call this
low effort because it maybe research
went into it and I'm not putting it down
and saying so but I just want to
encourage you that this person got
10,000 views
on like talking over a real time screen
share of their phone 10,000 views okay
so there's some videos in your 2024
future that are are easy to
make and but let's what is the other
Insight from this okay a lot of people
doing shorts to reveal that notice this
one got 313,000 views which would be
worth
studying okay also the resolution of
this is kind of blurry which is not a
problem because it got 313,000 views but
what what I'm seeing the initial things
I notice is like let's try to not
make oh by the way design with canva
canva to cropping in a circle 500,000
views objection well Sean there's
already some rank shorts there's already
some full length videos they and they're
a little bit older it looks like this
might be hard to crack
into a that's fair B I would say do it
anyway too many people are a avoiding
making basic videos or they're
overestimating the competition if you
verify interest in a video that already
has five
478,000
views then the chance of you getting 555
views with a new channel is Pretty
likely so I would say we're on to a
sound you know here's interesting six
months ago this one didn't do good I'm
wondering maybe why did it not do good
one reason why is perhaps this this
stock photo person in the thumbnail that
actually could be harmful people are
looking for real or they're just looking
for like the answer notice like this one
did better than this one but different
thing so here's here's what I'm saying
when I say use the YouTube search
bar I am
saying identify the topic that you want
to research that you want to make a
video about actually then search it and
then analyze the ranked results for
insights of what you could do better or
different so what could you do better or
different you might be able to if it's
mostly shorts or they're mostly low
quality or they're mostly old you might
be able to make a longer form video and
you're not fluffing it up but maybe
there's you could have more clarity
maybe there's been a major update to
canvas's interface there's lots of
things you could so your title ends up
becoming how to do a circle crop 2024
update or 2024 new feature so you need
to add on those layers and those
insights could come you'd be like oh
this person's using the old version
because this is the world you live in
like that person's using the old version
that person did it wrong that person did
it the hard way so you might say do it
the easy way and by analyzing the
results how long are the videos what
format are the videos what can I learn
about the thumbnails what can I learn
about the titles what got a lot of views
and and using a tool like vid IQ so you
could see who got a lot of views
compared to their subscribers or who got
a lot of views and actually the video
didn't get a lot of views because if a
channel has three million subscribers
and it got 50,000 views you might be
like oh 50,000 yeah but the channel has
three million subscribers so the video
could have flopped it actually could be
really underperforming but just the
sheer momentum of the person's
subscribers is why it got views these
are some of the insights that we could
glean from Simply using the auto predict
to get the idea and then actually going
to YouTube
search and seeing what's on the other
side number two Google
Trends so give me another
topic
Vonda asks side quest and we'll come
back how do you know if it's ranked well
you would know you know what's ranked by
just what ranks what rank what here's
what I mean the competitor's video so if
we say how to set up a
Woodworking Shop the ranked videos are
the first page and you could you could
play around with like Incognito if you
want incognito window but more or Le yes
sometimes you're your results are
personalized but actually not not that
much so there's going to be a lot to
learn on this first page you could
analyze the shorts look at shorts views
you analyze the thumbnails analyze the
age of the videos but the rank videos
are these top videos what can I learn
about these how do these individuals
structure the video could I structure my
video different sometimes you'll see
things like it's interesting if this is
five and this is 11 and this is 10
minutes long okay maybe length isn't an
issue in some cases you might see all
the rank videos are about 15 minutes so
if you're making videos that are
55 it's not that you couldn't be on the
first page but there's just certain
curiosity questions you want to be
asking Okay so we've got digital art
Christmas growth which one are we doing
here we're doing Google
Trends
um let's
go
let's go dating Niche won't work I think
it will that's my favorite challenge
telling me it won't work um real F rapid
recap here um would be now we're talking
about dating would be like how to
approach a girl there's how to okay a
girl you don't know a girl at the gym
you're crush a girl in college a girl in
volleyball specific questions maybe
you're making these broad dating videos
what about how to approach a girl at a
gym very specific thing that people are
looking for okay great howto uh dating
uh could you could say like dating
versus marriage dating versus
relationship dating versus courting
again interesting you you probably
wouldn't have thought maybe doing dating
versus marriage you were maybe would
maybe that's not a video that's relevant
for you totally fine but that's an
example of just what verses could lead
you to and then you might say like best
dating uh apps really good one by the
way best dating apps
2024 come back later and drop a Super
Chat tip for that one do the best dating
apps do the research do the best da and
maybe you already have sometimes that
seems obvious but sometimes I'm shocked
because if you're literally a dating
Channel and you're not making the best
dating apps we need to have a
talk so uh for sure it works with dating
um but let's hit another trend for uh
thank you appreciate you try that dating
app video and then let me know how it
goes
um okay I got the best dating app of
2024 sometimes what that might take
though is you you of course if you just
say the best dating app it's not going
to be a very good video people need
contrast in Conflict I even if it's true
I probably won't trust you if you're
just like you know Tinder is the best
dating app Christian Mingle is the best
dating app I need to know like I looked
at the top five ranked apps looked at
the pros and cons of each of them
because
again I am not giving you full I did say
these videos could be easy and these
videos have verified intent and these
videos have guaranteed views but I am
not giving you a hall pass to put lazy
effort into the final content content is
King and good content Rises
to is like cream it always Rises to the
top no matter how many cups of coffee
you pour so we do need to reinforce this
with good content the myth is that it
has to be super fancy or even like
profound but good content also could
look like actually you did the research
for people you thought about the pros
the cons the objections The Good The Bad
whatever and you packaged it well you
put some effort into structure of the
video all in service of the
viewer okay so now let's talk about
Google Trends one tool for your tool
belt is Google Trends and this can give
you a prediction of a couple things we
should probably make a whole video on
this so I'll kind of be brief
uh
but let's see let's
go let's
go South and North Carolina Business
Leaders no I don't know if that's is
that the niche it says
whiskey let's go Fitness Sophie okay so
if you're in Fitness so what kind of uh
Fitness Sophie like at home workouts
Fitness for
Women so when you're in Google Trends
there's a couple things we could do so
if we're starting here remember we're
saying okay uh how to get in shape fast
at
home okay
um the best way to get in shape fast
what can I learn from here it's a good
one um begin a workout Made Simple full
buddy workout so
now one of the biggest mistakes people
make is they haven't even done exactly
what I'm doing which was search bar
intent of the audience which we know
they want to get in shape fitness that's
Sophie's Niche seeing what videos are
ranked that's what we're seeing here
we're seeing what's on the other side of
how to get in shape fast at home and
then seeing the types of videos that are
are are uh have been made wow is this a
is this a robot is this a gaming channel
of just follow along with like a not
real person that has five million
subscribers that's cool I've never seen
that Chann um how to get bigger arms
which also would be the big opportunity
here because again if you are targeting
women in their
30s uh then how to get bigger arms in 30
days is probably not the main whatever
so so understanding some of those things
is a big deal we have some insight here
but maybe what I'm looking at would be
like um we're going to use Google and
then Google Trends what are the biggest
Fitness
trends of
2023 wearable technology hit Home Gyms
exercise snacking body weight training
okay great so forgive me I don't know
about stuff so I'm G to take hit over
here hit workout I'm gonna throw that in
Google Trends this is just one tool that
I'll use in not every circumstance but
you could select United States you could
say past uh let's go 12 months let's go
all categories okay and then let's go
YouTube search kind of cool so you can
say not just web search but YouTube
search all right now this peaks in
January doesn't surprise me there isn't
this just it's a it's a pretty much an
100 by January 29th as people are
committed to their goals and by the end
of December it's a 56 like one out of
you know um sort of a decline over the
years so this right now if you're aware
of your need
okay Fitness for students we'll see if
we can go a little bit deeper uh but
Sophie says Fitness for students I think
what we want to look for is different
topics and and then we could see what's
growing is hit growing is functional
fitness growing so let's also say okay
what are what are the best workout
Trends 2023 okay let's get back I'm
going to go hit body weight gamification
personal training
exercise exercise snacking that's the
one I want to
do I don't know what that means I
probably don't understand
it so uh no surprise but you also can
compare two things here so
notice
um the red line at the bottom versus the
blue line up above and so you also can
look in like a five so if you're a
gaming channel this is very powerful you
could see if a game is increasing in
popularity or not increasing this is
telling me like what hit workouts didn't
exist before 2021 or they kind of did
but talk about arise and popularity um
so these kind of things can be
interesting you can look at the how long
has that particular search term and
remember this is a free tool that can
give us Insight um to to think about a
direct application of how you might
apply this you know we of course make
camera reviews so in some cases what
we're asking oursel is again we're back
to like verifying interest so and comp
and seeing how big could a topic get so
you know Canon M50 throwback pretty
classic are people still looking for the
Canon
M50 uh it's been out five years notice a
massive rise in 2022 that makes sense as
soon as the lockdown happen in March
notice that rise right there as soon as
the lockdown happened inch March people
are at home wanting to start channels
and the Canon m50's popularity shot from
an 11 to a 53 that actually it was part
of the creater economy boom like Adobe
did a report that said 165 million
people join the creater economy in
2022 and it's actually maintained
popularity even though it's an older
camera it's down a little bit now it's
up because people are like new year new
you new camera when what they really
just need to do is watch this video and
use your current smartphone or your
current camera because it's much more
about okay it's much more about the
strategy right and the production like
getting inside of the mine so anyways
that's interesting There is five years
of the Canon M50 but what we can compare
that to is we could say Sony zve E10 and
you could start imagining how popular
this could or how powerful this could be
okay also super fascinating
because this SC the Sony zv E10 is I
mean it's Superior in probably every way
especially to the Canon M50 Mark 1 yet
the Canon M50 is still more
popular let's say I was coaching a tech
Channel right now this should actually
this is a mind-blowing
revelation
because your intuition might tell you
that camera's old that topic is old that
Topic's on the decline this is my
biggest pet peeve with like family
gatherings people
proposing factual information based off
their feelings in
emotions don't you hate the other guy
though these are people me I'm the other
guy the guy that's like can we google
and like actually look that up is that
true like the guy that like ruins your
party you're like you know what I heard
I heard that like everybody that takes
turmeric is like gonna get a tumor in
their face and you're like is that true
and they're like well I read it in
National Inquirer I was all right well
let's look that up so here's my thing is
my emotions and my conclusions of my
mind might tell me that the Canon M 50
is an irrelevant video to make what this
tells me and there is a formula for this
the title is is the Canon M50 still
relevant in
2024 it's still being searched there's
still a Google trend on it bigger than
maybe the newer camera you would think
would be more popular and what I'll end
up doing here is we could you know go
deeper and deeper and deeper and go Sony
zv one and there's different ways you
could word it I'm going to use the point
shoot camera thing here and then now
notice the layered lines we've got the
red versus the yellow versus the blue
and the Sony zv1 all things compared is
the bigger camera Canon M50 though
overall counting today is is the most
influential which together we're
experiencing this like I didn't know
that this was going to be the results
this is the power of the tool so let me
en encourage
you that
um this one I don't NE I don't use this
one every time I probably use this one
out of 10 times you know typing like
student Fitness into Google Trends isn't
really going to help you what what what
I'm after with the Google Trends one is
maybe a product name maybe a person name
something that's tangible and
influential it might be a search term
but what we then are projecting ahead is
we're projecting ahead like oh wow this
one has some velocity this has some
interest and remember
if you don't verify interest that be a
red flag and again too many people just
blaze
forward without verifying interest and
then are disappointed by the views this
is why when you research before you
press record it provides insights that
save you a lot of time a lot of energy a
lot of pain the pain of editing the pain
of uploading the pain of being
discouraged by a results let's like get
smart first I identify an idea and let's
hit number three which is Google search
and let me have one
other uh
topic hit me with your topics hit me
with your channel topics let's use
Google Search now this one will kind of
blow your mind some of the places we can
take this and um again smash like if
you're just jumping on the live stream
and uh check out the
uh check out
the replay of this video because this is
pretty rich and thick by the way if you
didn't know we're doing 12 Days of
Christmas Even though it's 2024 um and
we do have a special I have a giveaway a
winner announcement and I've got a code
for you and so uh maybe we can just
throw up here it is oh I just deleted it
I literally just put the delete button
Victoria the code is coffee the code is
coffee coffee with can the code is
coffee if if you know you know and we're
doing our 12 Days of Christmas and then
we also have a giveaway winner um what
did they win Victoria uh it but
congratulations to the watercolor
classroom for winning and we'll tell you
what you won I am from The 12 Days of
Christmas my goal for 2024 is to start
Evergreen live streaming on a regular
basis well thanks so much for being here
Becky and congratulations uh Victoria
will'll tell you what you want in just a
second and we can try to bring that
banner up I just deleted it also shout
out to AO hammer for the massive love so
grateful for the man you are today
thanks for everything you share Sean
someone for the mission DJ Blaze I
appreciate it she's referencing to an
episode where I got super vulnerable on
the podcast really shared my story that
I haven't shared before um and really
kind of just the early days how the ups
and downs maybe some surprising things
about my background
and running from God partying hard
trying to find my way and a lot of life
lessons as well
so uh check that out that episode is
called minimum wage to 1 million
subscribers my
story uh which is one of the recent
uploads and then here's that book
Episode by the way this book is a cheat
code for Content creation again not just
making a list of books but thinking
about how you could add value around the
books shout out to our uh evangelism
channel that we were talking about
earlier all right the code is
coffee and we're going to pick one more
Niche for our last thing so okay street
street photography Andy Street
photography so let's kind of recap the
whole video in a couple things we could
do with street photography and what
we're talking about we're talking about
the secret of using the YouTube search
bar to come up with video ideas and
topics that can get massive views or
guaranteed views so if we were to
say how to get
started in street
photography there's a how-to if we use
the YouTube search we could look on the
other side here what can we learn from
this video their thumbnail their
organization you know we're actually
kind of researching the ranked videos
here we could also say street
photography versus portrait versus
street photography 35 millimeter versus
50 that is a fire top because I right
most street photography cameras you're
kind of you are kind of a 35 millimeter
I don't know forgive me for uh
postulating
ignorance um but like look best prime
for S photograph so this also happened
by it stood out to me number one because
I went into the verses I didn't even
know it was going to give me millimeters
for for lenses which makes sense and
then we go deeper and we start seeing
okay some of the rank videos are 85
versus 50 this one's 24 a lot of people
are going way more they're doing three
here's one with just the two and notice
it verified once again 5,000 Subs 17,000
views remember this whole video is not
about actually helping you go viral this
video is helping you get guaranteed
views building up your library Brick by
Brick and also having videos that get
views while you're on
vacation so use this information it's
not the only strategy but it's probably
the most important beginner strategy in
2024 because again these videos could be
easier to make clear verified interest
so that was the verses we also might say
best street photography camera lens
photographers YouTube channels you could
shout out other channel it's a good way
to collab all kinds of ways you could
take that just from going that direction
then of course we could we're
researching here we could look at Google
Trends what's going up or down regarding
that but that was a recap of the whole
video on street photography to take this
over to Google and use Google for a
couple things one you could also type in
best street photography and these
predictions are probably going to be
different than YouTube That's thing one
the Google search bar pred predictions
are probably going to be
different I would say verified interest
here is good enough for me so if I was
to be typing something in this and
YouTube didn't autocomplete for me but
Google did I'd still do it because
Google owns YouTube we get over two
million views a year from uh Google from
YouTube videos so beginners cheap all
this kind of stuff but what I like would
be like tips for getting started on only
fans tips for getting started
with street photography all right that's
what we're after okay uh tips street
photography tips from beginners this is
an interesting little window here and
here's why this is so
powerful famous quote from Steve Jobs
quoting Pablo Picasso quoting the person
who actually said it no I don't know who
said it but uh I think it was Pablo
Picasso that said good artist copy great
artist steal Steve Jobs quoted him he
said listen we've never been we've never
hesitated from asking what are the best
ideas what is the best information what
is the best way of doing it and then
taking those best ideas and those best
practices and putting it into our
original products so good artist copy
great artist steal is not an advocation
for plagiarism but it is advocating that
there's really nothing new Under the Sun
shout out to King Solomon and you're
looking at you're going to create an
original product because your video
communicated your way is is going to be
um incredibly powerful so this third
tool of just using Google
search will also help in the outlining
of the video and so here's a couple
thoughts of how I might do that number
one tips for getting started in street
photography is what I typed in number
two uh here these are from sources
across the web this just made a
list of what does tell a story mean what
does understand your camera mean you
could probably quick quickly come up
with a video a if if you know how to do
all of this because this is I'm just
trying to get my brain primed meaning
that sometimes when I do this I like I
already know that I should ask for
permission in street photography model
release or you know ask for permission
whatever but maybe I forgot to include
that in my list so the heavy lift here
is that we're crowdsource the actual
tips like you can make a video called
like 21 tips for getting started in
street photography and these might be
the tips I'm not indic I'm not saying
you shouldn't if you if you actually
believe you should be rude and not
respectful then don't include that one
but that's a great tip right and you can
even go deeper and it shows you the
resources um but you might be like oh
yeah I I like I do that intuitively but
I wouldn't have thought to to mention
that so I am IND I'm encouraging you to
use OPC other people's content to
inspire your video so we have all these
street photography tips maybe you take
your top five or your top 10 off this
maybe you use them all to make a more
comprehensive video we've barely got
down the page and we're already getting
a lot of value out of Google Search next
too many people missed the opportunity
of taking a YouTube
video no no no taking a
ranked article and turning it into a
video if the research we're doing is
verifying interest then what better way
to verify interest that hum
really like a particular topic and
title because Google ranked the the the
post so what do I mean exactly I mean
you typed in tips for getting started
with street photography because that was
our topic that was submitted here on
coffee with canel we then see that the
top ranked article is from photography
life it's a couple years old and it's
called the complete guide to street
photography for
beginners now there's other ways we
could have come upon that idea but let
me just suggest to you that if you have
a street street photography channel that
it would be probably Advantage it would
be a good video to make would be the
complete guide to street photography for
beginners in
2024 and that my friend was us going
from the YouTube search bar all the way
over to Google to to id8 but then what
gets more interesting is we could click
through and be like
okay so here's the table of
contents yikes you want to talk about
outlining your videos you're like so so
hey welcome to this video we're check
out time codes and chapters in the
beginning we're going to be covering a
lot of things what is street photography
how to make a greet the great Street
photograph uh do Street photos need
people the pros and cons are Street are
is all street photography candid I'm
going to be sharing some camera
equipment and street photography I'm
going to talk about the code of conduct
some things as far as working with
people that the table they outlined your
video and again you make the video
smaller longer delete some things add
some things but so much heavy lift has
happened and not only that this content
itself has been
verified to please people at some level
because it's a top ranking article on
Google but how many people want to watch
this in video format and again I'm not
saying plagiarize this but I'm saying
look at how much you can learn from the
heavy lifting that's already been done
and we could go deeper you could jump
into Reddit here which is a whole
different tool but Google ranked it and
look at maybe some different tips you
might read this and and inspire a video
called five unusual street photography
tips because you're like oh that's a
good point yeah that happened to me when
I was in bise that was a good point like
and and it helps you again formulate
your next video and if we go a little
bit deeper we could see others uh every
street photography tip and technique
five techniques these are good too I'm
pumped about about this stuff linger and
let the action come to you I get it
smart uh walk slow and don't take things
for granted
acting what to say if you get caught
pretty good like good stuff so again and
and then any one of these tips might
Inspire an entire video all from
following our curiosity path
of using Google search and seeing what
comes up and what shows up so I want to
answer a couple of your
questions and uh let's recap though we
talked about these three YouTube topic
formulas we're using the YouTube search
bar you're using how to versus and best
and then the three tools are using the
YouTube search bar by actually searching
it once you've identified the topic
perhaps using Google Trends or going to
Google search and then building out your
topic your script your
outline everything that has happened in
this by using this process has not only
verified interest in
the topics but it also has essentially
verified interests in the information
what do I mean if you if you take an
article and turn it into a video but the
article already perform well arguably
the video will perform well there's
Nuance to it but it's already proven so
we we are we have such a gift by
using all this data that's already on
YouTube and Google and that gift helps
us avoid pain and hardship for making
videos nobody wants to see from sharing
information that people aren't super
interested in and again these are just a
few tools that I hope will serve you
that are in your tool belt for
2024 I've got some coffee with CLE
questions to hit uh but let me know your
biggest aha moment and take away from
this and as a reminder there's only
about 48 hours left on think media
sale.com one of the biggest reasons to
pick this up you could see this orange
graphic here the YouTube Road mapap
Workshop you get a ticket and you could
attend live this Saturday
or uh the replays will be provided a
replay of the training let's get your
YouTube plan right for 2024 let's get
your strategy right your plan right your
Clarity right your topic right of your
whole Channel like you're branding um
and let's talk about some of the changes
to YouTube as well as what's working on
YouTube right now again the best way to
get a ticket to YouTube roadmap is think
Medias
sale.com and then than media sale.com
also this is our holiday bundle New
Year's bundle and it's ending this
Saturday hard stop not false scarcity
this year we've gotten more positive
feedback on this um sale than ever
before people are loving these resources
I think it's only
$57 skip the trip to Olive Garden skip
three days at Starbucks and you could
pick this up right so anyways um if
you're not serious about doing YouTube
in 2024 and you know no big deal no
pressure but just FYI it's it's
literally an incredible sale I think
over $600 worth of resources for 67 $57
thi Medias sale.com ending soon and I
would love to connect with you on the
road map um we do have a couple super uh
chats Mark says I appreciate your
helpful content I appreciate you mark uh
thanks so much I like that Sylvia's New
Year's resolution is to use Google
Trends more I like that Sylvia and then
let's see Andy says thank you for
helping me out with street photography
topics I'm 15 Subs away from 1K let's go
we're going to celebrate together for
sure Andy you're going to hit it a I
think that the chance to break down kind
of how all those tools and you kind of
got a a trip inside of my mind in
regards
to like if I'm you like how I'm gonna
sort of identify a great video to make
build out a good you know good content
around that so anyways appreciate you
thanks so much for your generous Super
Chat and let's do some rapid fire Q&A um
by the way congratulations water class
water room classroom who won from the 12
Days of Christmas you get a live
streaming
kit side note if you're not on like our
newsletter I hope you're getting emails
from us maybe at one time you were and
you're like I haven't seen them check
your junk mail your spam folder search
for think Media or Sean canel in your um
email inbox add us to your safe senders
because we're always doing cool stuff
like that not only will we give you like
summaries of the best videos and content
you may have missed and trainings like
this um other master classes that come
up but we do things like the 12 Days of
Christmas we're doing giveaways 12 days
in a row and all free stuff really cool
and that just was happening on our you
know basically email newsletter and
email list and so definitely jump on
there you know it would probably be
smart for us to make it easy for people
to jump on there but the way to get on
there
is if you've registered for anything at
any time so if you go to like think
Master Class I'm actually doing a
another one of our master classes live
tonight um think masterclass.com it
registers you for the class but it also
gets you on the newsletter but I
hopefully most of our community is
getting that information just super
valuable and we're doing the 12 Days of
Christmas buckle your seat belt we's see
how many of these we could get to
Kevin I heard that you should not tell
your friends on social media about your
channel because it could throw off the
algorithm and your video may not be what
that person
views
one of the biggest mistakes people make
is telling their friends and family
about their YouTube channel and here's
why if you share one of your YouTube
videos with your friends and family
unless they happen to be just as
passionate about the topic they're into
that Niche and their YouTube consumers
them clicking on it and viewing and
subscribing is pointless and it could be
harmful because if your mom is like oh
honey you started a YouTube channel so
proud of you all subscribe and maybe
she's active on YouTube but all she
watches is Miniatures videos DIY videos
of like homemaking stuff how to make
good Arnold Palmer and lemonade and
where where are we the Masters and she
ultimately is like watching all this
stuff but she clicks on your gaming
channel and she's not into it then what
YouTube's always doing is it's trying to
group it's trying to identify what your
Channel's about and who else would be
interested in your channel and they're
like wait a minute like
moms that are into Miniatures are also
into this gaming because because your
mom's not ultimately into your channel
she's just supporting you your friends
probably aren't consistent YouTube
consumers maybe and they're not into
your channel so actually the mistake
people make is sometimes they can
promote their Channel just to get vanity
views or vanity subscribers when they
don't actually attract people who find
the channel on its own merits or find it
because they're genuinely interested in
the topic itself s so you're better
off doing two things number one
following the training I just taught and
creating search-based content that
attracts people legitimately interested
in your content that are finding it
based on that interest you know like
there's no reason you're searching
Coleman
tense versus Northface tense if you're
not interested in tense and camping like
it would be pretty irrational that that
would be where you find yourself on
YouTube so now you know you're
attracting somebody that's into camping
that's into Outdoors Etc so that'd be a
good subscriber potentially and a good
follow of your channel so that's thing
one thing two is when you promote your
videos I think it is good to promote
them in a polarizing way and I what I
mean by polarizing is like not being
afraid to say only only watch this this
video is only for um you know and and
here's a better way to say it if I was
promoting on X and Twitter and I said
just uploaded a new video on how to grow
your YouTube channel in 2024 that's
probably self filtering because if you
don't want to grow a YouTube channel in
2024 you probably wouldn't click on
it if I said how to grow a you know use
YouTube to get more leads and clients
for Real Estate also self- filtering
because if you don't do real estate and
you're not a real estate agent you
probably wouldn't click on it so that
would be fine to promote because your
mom's not like oh I'm gonna go check out
that real estate because she's not in
real estate but sometimes I will
verbally say or will'll say it in email
or in text we say like this is for you
if you are you're going to love this
video if you're a business owner that's
already doing over six figures a year um
because the clearer you are the the the
Creator who understands the viewer best
wins and so and if YouTube understands
your channel it'll help you win because
YouTube does want to associate you kind
of with keywords and Concepts and topics
to be like oh this is a street
photography channel so in some summary
if your mom is passionate about street
photography then you should invite her
to your Channel about street photography
but in general I would not try to just
get views and subscribers from random
people in your life that are ultimately
just going to hurt the
algorithm John asks monetizing a channel
that potentially is geared towards kids
can it be done and
how John with this one I'm just going to
recommend a video we'll link it up um
it's difficult it the way to do it is SC
and what do I mean this might sound
obvious but like blippy is doing pretty
well like financially like
blippy is doing all right um Ryan's toy
reviews is doing all right how do they
do it well now Netflix specials brand
deals and insane amounts of views the
problem with views on kids content is
it's monetized differently and so the
exact math is broken down in this video
advice for kids channels money views and
challenges from someone who really knows
what they're talking about Matt Gillan
so we'll link that up in the show notes
if you're a kids Creator there's a great
video to watch very Niche information
but very powerful it can be done John
but let me just tell you it is a little
bit difficult randomax A fungi when you
do research and search on YouTube do you
get different results because of
Premium I mentioned this a little bit
earlier but I don't
overthink YouTube search results when
doing my research meaning me being
logged in versus me not being logged in
me uh having Premium versus not premium
incognito window versus not incognito
window by the way incognito window is
the
secret and all that simply means is on
Google Chrome if we go up here I don't
know how to do it what do you click here
bookmark install
app how do you do it oh new incognito
window so now I'm not logged in I go to
YouTube I'm not logged in I search how
to start I mean there's probably nothing
better you could do than this because
you're not logged in you're not in
premium now you're seeing how to start
street photography sponsored post that's
an ad then you're seeing the ranked
video and this was the same ranked video
from earlier but you might get slightly
different video uh results but I would
argue it's inconsequential to the the
feedback loop your still getting
sometimes like that video is three down
versus number one incognito window
probably solves it um don't get me
wrong a a seasoned algorithm even that's
not logged in meaning someone's been
consuming YouTube videos on it will
affect
recommendations but it doesn't really
affect search results from my experience
what it what it's maybe marginally but
it's inconsequential so but the shortcut
would just be open up an incognito
window if you're really trying to get
like an unbiased just like fully
unbiased idea of of what could you learn
from the ranked videos on the homepage
great
question what about using AI tools to
create the
videos yeah so well that's a can of
worms I encourage you to subscribe we're
going to talk I think I'm going to do a
dedicated AI episode I have so much to
say about AI in our seven big trends
podcast that's coming out soon
um but one YouTube's kind of cracking
down on AI of course mainly if it's deep
fakes if you're imitating other people
and their likeness or their voice maybe
if the video is fully generated
sometimes voiceovers it's it's a little
complex of a question to ask like should
you use
AI yeah you absolutely by the way our AI
guide is included in our think Medias
sale.com and so this is pretty crazy our
I guide you can see on the right side
here is the best tools we've researched
thousands of hours of research now
between myself Brian Melissa Nolan Omar
the best AI tools and it's a living
document so we keep updating it um and
so when you
say should you use AI to
like to create what about using AI tools
to create the videos there's two things
I think I feel like you could mean there
number
one like Bard Google Bard assisted me in
the creation of my Trends video mainly
because Bard is so good at giving me
data and stats and references and
articles better than chat gbt in my
experience so I used AI in the creation
of it I'm pretty sure that Steph when
editing used uses autopod or Samy and so
they throw the long footage in there and
then autopod the angle switches and so
instead of two hours of editing it's a
couple minutes of editing so should you
use AI tools as a content creator if
you're not you're being
foolish but should you fully create the
video with AI there's different tools we
covered one on think media from n video
and some different things I think that's
up to you I think that it's a little bit
it's Shaky Ground because we don't know
what the these YouTube regulations are
going to be it's kind of like I
encourage people like I encourage
musicians to to do to include popular
music or even covers and they go what if
I get demonetized and I go well who
cares if you get demonetized aren't you
trying to get popular aren't you trying
to get known aren't you trying to get
views would you would you rather only
have 10 videos with 10,000 views but
they're all
monetized but nobody knows you or would
you rather have a video get 10 million
views that isn't monetized nine more
videos that are um but the 10 million
viewed video gets you tons of
subscribers tons of awareness leads to a
record deal leads to opening up doors of
opportunity that's kind of what I mean
so sometimes we're we're too myopically
focused on YouTube monetization like oh
YouTube demonetized the video yeah but
if it's still getting reach and and it's
growing your popular you could have
different videos in your library doing
different
things so but the reason AI is Shaky
Ground is it's uncertain what YouTube's
regulations are going to be and that's
why I encourage some people even when it
comes to fair use I'm a pro- fair use
guy using OPC other people's content but
it's risky it's riskier than only you
being in the videos because for sure
this is only me and like there's nothing
in this video that's if you will
copywritten or whatever so it's a big
can of worms should should you use it I
think you can I think you can experiment
I think you should be experimenting I
think you could try
uh I it's AI is going to disrupt so much
to ignore it would be foolish but that's
a topic for another day
Ryan I want to start a Christian YouTube
channel talking headstyle go over the
Bible says about specific P passages and
topics would it be a good idea would a
good first video be about tattoos yeah
Ryan like this is a good topic
um funny thing about Christian channels
is we mentioned at the beginning of this
video you should be making more basic
videos in 2024 more beginner videos or
more simple videos or more obvious
videos what surprises me is people have
Bible channels and they haven't
made 10 videos on the 10 biggest
questions people ask about what the
Bible says so even if someone's already
made it I don't care make it you should
make it too even if it's kind of obscure
if it if there's verified interest you
should make
it and right now we're going to use the
YouTube search bar to show you exactly
what I mean
so what does the Bible say about Israel
tattoos cremation marriage dinosaurs
hell divorce Heaven alcohol sex money
fasting Halloween and days there's your
next 14 videos
Sir and some of these will have more
competition than others there's
obviously lots of different angles you
could take but there is literally the 14
videos If exactly what you just said
Ryan there's the layup that's applying
this in practice and man if if most if
people would just do this they would get
so many more views than talking about 14
things their next 14 videos I don't know
what they're about but just they're
titled bad they don't make sense nobody
cares nobody wants to watch them so
there's a yeah that's what I would do
Ryan's great
question Jared what should be the
average length to get the most views for
these three kinds of
videos okay
so impossible to answer question but I
mentioned earlier that
longer is
better there's
video length will continue to increase
and big creators are showing this trend
that 25 to 30 minute videos are doing
really well and one hour to two hour
video podcasts are doing really well now
the problem is people are looking for
some magic formula five minute do videos
do great as well like and you should do
your research in every Niche case this
is what I
mean the expectation of the audience for
length is going to be different like if
I was like World War II to
history maybe my mentality is I'm ready
to go 30 to 60 Minutes I want like some
rich video essay documentary that's my
intent if I was to go
like five best foods for losing weight I
don't necessarily I don't need five
hours for that five minutes sounds great
so I think the topic matters for the
length so you saying the way you grouped
it and this is a really good Q&A session
because we're providing Nuance on
everything I just taught
these three kinds of videos are in a way
not a kind of video they're formulas how
to fill in the blank ver this versus
that um best this the actual video
itself still has to be discovered by you
so if you discover the three best lenses
for street photography then I would
argue that video should probably be
around 15 minutes but let's let's let's
actually go check that would be the
final step what is the best lenses for
street
photography see what ranks but let's see
how long the videos are top one is
sponsored not not
ranked so we got 12 minutes 13
minutes uh an ad 13 minutes 15 minutes
an ad8 minutes 19 minutes 64,000 on the
8 Minute viewed video 112 on the 20
minute
video the higher rank video are getting
like 36 36 so so again and this is all
somewhat subjective but what it reveals
to me is like three minute videos are
not doing
good even fives not really so when I say
longer videos too get it over eight you
have you know more opportunity for
earning more on ad Revenue but these
days number one I I refuse to answer the
question because it could Lead You
astray it it's it should be determined
by you doing your research and then
making an educated guess slash informed
strategic
decision as to what would be best for
the exact final topic you land on but if
I was going to default towards what
YouTube wants they want minutes most
they want people on the platform minutes
matter most time on platform matters
most so longer is better if it's not
full of fluff if it's if the topic
necessitates a longer video and you
could pack it full of value and you
could keep audience retention it'll it
will perform better because it'll keep
people on the platform longer that's the
logic all right I gotta go meet my uh a
contractor for a remodel we're doing so
I can answer like two more
questions congrats again Becky just
cycling through these so we already hit
that how do you know if a video is
ranked we already hit that what about
adding controversy to these how-to
versus and best you're again you're
right on track
so so by using the three formulas how to
fill in the blank this versus that best
lenses for street photography best home
workouts body weight workouts or
something okay so you use the formulas I
am not suggesting in a 2024 World that
you
necessarily just use these
predicted like by the way 24mm street
photography is a horri
title but it is predicted like 24 versus
35 there's a lot more that is that needs
to be there what we're doing though is
we're verifying that people are
comparing those two focal lengths then
the next skill we need is the skill of
writing great titles so notice Pierre
here said the final title for his video
which got 168,000 views is is 24
millimeter to wide for street
photography which also reveals like
that's that would reveals a couple
things to me one he's in his Niche he's
living it and he's understanding how his
audience think and he's maybe thinking
about questions they answer so maybe
what you know is like Fact one is people
want to talk about 24 millimeter lenses
for street
photography but then if we were to do
like a mind map we could Splinter off a
lot of ways to take that a video could
be is 24 millimeter to wide for street
photography and then you know that's
remember English Clash that's like your
thesis that's the thesis and you build a
video out around that a whole different
direction to go would be 24
mm versus 35 millimeter lenses
compared that's telling me maybe that
like show me this photo versus that
photo like hey do you want to see the
difference of the two focal lengths so
you can get a visual idea that would
insinuate that you need to have photo
examples or hit record on your
mirrorless camera and and show the
different whatever so
again this these formulas
are a starter to come up with verified
great ideas but then you saying
controversy controversy is just one way
of powering up a title or or being
better at Psychology or marketing and so
if appropriate absolutely
like 24 millimeter versus 35 millimeter
anyone who uses 24 MIM is stupid kind of
mean kind of rude but like sometimes the
title sort of like shows you the slant
and it's
controversial should you do this or that
hint uh don't you know like here's what
we
did um for the Sony
zv1 when it came out I saw this is a
pretty powerful strategy when the Sony
zv1 came
out
um everyone you know cameras are have
competition so everyone was making a
video about it right
fine like the day it came out too and I
don't I don't think we got it early we
oftentimes Wonder like dude Sony what
are you thinking but whatever um so I
don't know if we had I don't think we we
didn't have it or we did I think we did
here what's the point the point was um
everyone when it came to the Sony
zv1
was was
uh like really positive about
it and it was all like best camera ever
finally blah blah blah blah blah now I
verified interest on the Sony zb1
whatever so I knew the topic you could
see my video up top 352,000 vid uh views
it's a streamed video it's it's not even
a very great video I mean it's all
whatever it's all subjective but like I
kind of
just okay here's the takeaway uh best
camera for vlogging question mark hint
it's not the Sony
zv1 and one of if you will the tactics
or strategies that I think led to the
performance of that video is we were
contrarian to what everybody else was
saying it's controversy because everyone
was like it's the best camera best for
vlogging we're like no it's not and to
give you the
backstory this was from doing my
research from thinking about what could
be different than the way that everybody
else is saying it and from not also not
invalidating my love for that camera why
is it not the best camera for vlogging
because because it's too tight literally
they released meaning that it zooms in
too far it doesn't Zoom it's not wide
enough the reason the Sony zv1 is not
the best camera for vlogging in its
native state is it's not wide enough at
arms length maybe with the selfie stick
maybe with the screw on lens that's
actually a glue on lens that screws on
that Omar talks about but what's the
point is that literally the Mark I
version the second version Sony released
has a wider lens to solve that problem
but the punch line is after doing
research then it's like okay what's the
angle what's the psychological angle
what's the unique angle what's the way
to do if you will the opposite of what
everybody else is doing and it also stir
up a little
conversation but I wasn't just trying to
be dramatic for dramatic sake I needed
real information to back that up and the
real information was
listen for the intent of vlogging by
itself it's not the best vlogging camera
there's some accessories you you could
add to it but then that kind of you know
which is fine but again all we're
talking about is an angle positioning
title thumbnail packaging so by all
means controversy is incredibly powerful
um and as a side note
um this is why some of the title
formulas we do here like if all you uh
if you already picked up our think media
sale.com I want to encourage open up the
15 best YouTube title
formulas and make those 15 videos in the
next three months according to your
nishe this this sale is only $57 but if
all you did was just went through the 15
best YouTube title formulas which again
those are more powerful than just like a
list of ideas those have science-backed
psychological principles behind them
like the one I just kind of described
talking about the Sony zb1 and so that's
the kind of thinking that we want to
help you with in 2024 so you can grow
your Channel get subscribers get views
and and uh controversy is one tool and
not a tool you have to force or not a
tool you should use if it doesn't work
or make sense or there's not an angle
for using it but when it's appropriate
when you feel it and when you learn how
to kind of think this way and package
your videos better honestly you're G to
get better results and I think that'll
really serve you so listen um coffee
with canel is the
show this year a couple updates think
media fam
probably be doing these about two a
month if not more but probably roughly
two a month coffee with canel a lot of
times we'll have guests on usually these
those are our video raik Academy
students or V Elite students pay this is
why you should be on the email because
there will probably be a couple times
we'll lob it out and we have people get
locked in ahead of time but those are
prescheduled where we also go through
their Channel that's just how we're
doing those lately um and we will
certainly do some ones that are open up
just to our Channel subscribers but you
gota I hope you're looking at the
community tab or notifications are on
because there's usually only two or
three slots per episode there'll be more
episodes like this with deeper dive
training in fact let me know if you
liked me just kind of going deep and
teaching I wanted to kind of Kick the
year off with some super tactical stuff
for you so let me know your AA moments
or your takeaways and may be what your
favorite things or any coffee with Cano
ideas and even better hashtag replay
famam always have massive love that
you're hanging out with me an hour and
40 minutes and 16 seconds into the
replay insane Happy New Year to you and
uh thank you so much for the love and
support but if you have Ana aha moment I
can also review the chat and the stream
or any ideas for coffee with canel but
uh it's our live show here on the fake
media podcast probably twice a month
minimum we'll have some guests we'll
have tips we'll have more Q&A like this
and uh I am committed to helping you win
on YouTube this year um the landscape is
changing there are some challenges and
Giants to slay but I'm confident that
with the right skill set the right
mindset the right support the right
Community the right information that you
can get an edge and that's what this
channel is all about so I hope you've
been uh getting value hope you love the
show if you're new here thanks so much
for being here and uh would love any
kind of feedback and stuff that you have
definitely check out thick Medias
sale.com before the sale ends this
Saturday if you're going to join me on
the road map can't wait to see you this
Saturday appreciate you random ax of fun
fungi uran says my ah was this complete
video I love hearing that I'm glad
you're getting value Gloria thanks so
much for being here Vonda appreciates
you sending you massive love and respect
the Swedish Car Guy thanks for rolling
over the years my friend it means the
world to me just to see your comments to
see the Avatar to see the support to see
the love I do not take it for granted
every time you've click like on a video
commented shared and uh I read as many
uh comments as possible always I
actually pretty much read probably near
100 % I hard as many as I can don't get
to respond to as many as I I can but I
but I really pay attention so when I
throw out Community tab questions and
whatnot um I'm looking for insight to
make better content for you so I
appreciate that Andy I could still
probably land a click kickflip right now
I'm 40 I don't know if that's a good
idea because it might take me five to 10
tries and I may fall and break my
tailbone but I'm down bro like if we
could I got a skateboard in my garage
you make me want to go down and try
right now so I could still kickflip
maybe Allie down a five stair
uh my aha moment here in the perspective
from the Music Channel 10 minutes ago
David I'm glad that that added some
value we're we'll cover some music stuff
gaming stuff this year as well and uh
Swedish car guy because of you I even
did my 2024 content idea board let's go
prior planning prevents poor
performance and uh three new video ideas
because of this very stream well if you
got value out of the stream and you know
other creators out there then it also
means the world if you share these
episodes and whatnot man I love all the
love y'all are pouring out really Mark
appreciate the
love uh thank you 808
ladybugs glad yes V V Elite let's build
this is your year come on Mahalo
appreciate you let's build you got Brian
Brooke crushing it V Elite man that that
program is going to be insane this year
our event by the way is coming up uh in
April in Las Vegas Grow video live.com
where we can hang out in person limited
iners tickets not streaming so uh
definitely come out in person and uh man
love
y'all to Shai did I hit your name right
T Shai travels V Let's Go appreciate you
sending you massive love and uh all
right I gotta go meet this general
contractor coffee with Kel my name is
Sean canel RS with YouTube channel
thanks for being a part of this uh
stream smash like and I will see you in
a future video